[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
ich habe ja gesagt twittert olaf scholz
zum foto mit blumen mehr ja zur wahl zum
amt ja zu der koalition auf die er sich
stützen will
guten abend die kanzlerin ist jetzt also
ein mann ein mann den die bevölkerung
schon lange in bundespolitischen
spitzenämter kennt er steht für
kontinuität in einer ansonsten sehr
neuen konstellation eine ampel so ein
dreierbündnis hatten wir im bund noch
nicht und sowohl grüne als auch fdp
waren dort lange nicht mehr an der macht
es wird interessant werden zu beobachten
die dieses neue kabinett zusammen findet
im neuanfang liegt heute zugleich ein
abschied von einer kanzlerin die wie
ihre vorgänger im amt wuchs und eine der
wenigen menschen ist die wirklich wissen
was auf den neuen persönlich zukommt was
es bedeutet in dieses amt zu ziehen
ich wünsche ihnen von herzen alles gute
bei dieser arbeit und immer eine
glückliche hand für unser land und diese
wünsche erstrecken sich auch auf das
ganze team
zweifellos ein historischer tag da lohnt
es sich auch noch mal ins geschichtsbuch
zu schauen olaf scholz ist der neunte
kanzler der bundesrepublik der vierte
seit der wiedervereinigung er wird sich
damit ein rein in die ahnengalerie der
republik der als gemäldesammlung im
bundeskanzleramt verewigt ist
1949 wurde konrad adenauer zum ersten
kanzler der bundesrepublik deutschland
gewählt damit begann eine 20-jährige cdu
regierung auf adenauer folgte sein
wirtschaftsminister ludwig erhard der
jedoch eher glücklos von der fdp
verlassen wurde
1966 übernahm kurt georg kiesinger cdu
kanzler der ersten großen koalition
dieses bündnis werte nur bis zur wahl
1969 dann übernahm für immerhin 13 jahre
die sozialdemokraten das kanzleramt
zunächst mit willy brandt der die spd
1972 zu ihrem größten wahlsieg führte
zwei jahre später aber zurück trat auf
ihn folgte helmut schmidt dass seine spd
ihn nicht mehr folgte und der
koalitionspartner fdp die seiten
wechselte nach dem misstrauensvotum
1982 bezug der cdu-vorsitzende helmut
kohl das bonner kanzleramt um dort 16
jahre zu bleiben
1998 wollten die wähler den wechsel mit
gerhard schröder gab es wieder einen
spd-kanzler bis zu den vorgezogenen
neuwahlen 2005 mit angela merkel kann
deutschland dann erstmals eine
bundeskanzlerin
und auch sie kam um zu bleiben 16 jahre
lang mit dem heutigen tag geht das amt
wieder an die spd über die wahl und
vereidigung von olaf scholz und seinem
ampel kabinett berichtet thomas reichert
die kanzler werde und dass olaf scholz
beginnt etwas suchen und mit langem
applaus für seine vorgängerin ich
begrüße auf der ehrentribüne die
geschäftsführende bundeskanzlerin frau
dr angela merkel merkel ist auf der
tribüne weil sie den bundestag nicht
mehr angehört alle fraktionen stehen auf
alle außer der a s man sieht merkel an
dass der applaus sie rührt der
machtwechsel nach 16 jahren ist ein
platzwechsel für merkel von der
regierungsbank zu den altvorderen zukauf
zu thierse zu gerhard schröder
[Applaus]
die kanzlerwahl beginnt jeder
abgeordnete wird einzeln aufgerufen
seinen stimmzettel abzugeben der
abgeordnete scholz aber olaf scholz
entweder er hört es nicht oder scholz
ist überzeugt dass er persönlich zu spät
dran ist ist er dann auch nicht mit ja
haben gestimmt
395 abgeordnete damit ist scholz zum
kanzler gewählt wenn auch mit einem
kleinen dämpfer weil ein paar stimmen
der ampel fehlen ich frage sie herr
abgeordneter scholz nehmen sie die wahl
an
das war laut und vernehmlich vor allem
aber so krank und knapp wie scholz geben
oft ist üppig sind nur die blumensträuße
armin laschet der unterlegene kandidat
der union gratuliert hast einer der
ersten guten morgen ist bleibt karg und
knapp auch in schloss bellevue ein
bundespräsidenten
im namen der bundesrepublik deutschland
er nenne ich herrn olaf scholz zum
bundeskanzler ein ganz herzlichen
glückwunsch und
dann wieder zurück in den bundestag
ortswechsel der entscheidende
platzwechsel das erste mal auf dem
kanzler stuhl
und die vereidigung
ich schwöre dass ich meine kraft dem
wohle des deutschen volkes widmen seinen
nutzen mehren schaden von ihm wenden das
grundgesetz und die gesetze des bundes
wahren und verteidigen meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen und gerechtigkeit
gegen jedermann üben werde so wahr mir
gott helfe anders als bei merkel gehe
die schröder tradition
noch einmal geht's zum bundespräsidenten
diesmal mit allen ministern die
ernennungsurkunden blaues leder mit
goldenem bundesadler auf dem weg zurück
in den bundestag stauen sich die
dienstlimousinen nur gäste mehr packt
die urkunde auf den gepäckträger und
radelt schon mal vor
im bundestag am ende die vereidigung der
minister
ich schwöre ich schwöre es so wahr mir
gott helfe der machtwechsel ist
vollzogen die ampel übernimmt ein
historischer einschnitt der sich
erstaunlich nüchtern fast
selbstverständlich vollzieht
nach dem feierlichen pendelverkehr
zwischen bundestag und bundespräsident
ging es am nachmittag an die praktische
seite des machtwechsels die übergabe von
kanzleramt und ministerien
und wenn sich die güte einer demokratie
auch daran bemisst welche akzeptanz die
jeweiligen wahlverlierer an den tag
legen die sich ein regierungswechsel
vollzieht und wie sich die benehmen die
gehen müssen und dann war das heute
schon mal ein guter tag für die deutsche
demokratie eigentlich eine demokratische
selbstverständlichkeit aber in einer
welt in der in anderen großen mächten
ein unblutiger wechsel kaum denkbar ist
und selbst in demokratien die
polarisierung und zu nehmen in dieser
welt also sieht man doch vielleicht
gerne in welchem ton und stil man sich
heute in berlin die klinken in die hand
gab andreas künast hat das für uns
beobachtet
es sind vor allem praktische fragen die
die achte bundeskanzlerin und der neunte
an diesem nachmittag noch klären müssen
dazu gehört wo steht der stuhl des neuen
hausherrn wohin mit der maske nachher
beim abschiedsfoto und wohin jetzt mit
den blumen dann ist olaf scholz
angekommen im kanzleramt sehr geehrter
herr bundeskanzler hieber olaf scholz
ich weiß aus eigenem erleben dass es ein
bewegender moment ist in dieses amt
gewählt zu werden sie ja an vielleicht
dass es eine spannende erfüllende
aufgabe ist auch eine fordernde aufgabe
aber wenn man sie mit freude an geht
dann ist es vielleicht auch eine der
schönsten aufgaben die es gibt so sieht
der machtwechsel aus blumenstrauß gegen
regierungszentrale sie haben großartiges
bewegt sagt scholz sie haben die maske
noch aussagen die fotografen
sie haben dieses land geprägt und auch
diese regierung und auch dieses haus und
ich will gerne anknüpfen an die wie soll
man das sagen nordostdeutsche mentalität
die da bisher geherrscht so viel wird
sich da nicht ändern
nur geöffnet bei über garten des hauses
und bei staatsempfängen
überall im regierungsviertel werden an
diesem nachmittag erst ministerien
erklärt und dann übergeben
agrarministerin klöckner hat einen
grünen nachfolger cem özdemir ihnen und
bauminister seehofer hat zwei rote
innenministerin feser und bauministerin
geiwitz
wirtschaftsminister altmaier übergibt an
robert habeck und alle danken heute
allen ich möchte mich bedanken bei
meinen fahrern die meine monologe
ausgehalten haben während der vielen
vielen fahrten von a nach b und immer so
taten als seien sie interessiert an dem
was der minister zu erzählen hat die
neue inhaberin der befehls und
kommandogewalt
verteidigungsministerin lamprecht wird
mit militärischen ehren begrüßt ihre
vorgängerin kramp karrenbauer fehlt
annalena baerbock die erste deutsche
außenministerin bricht noch am abend zu
ihrem antrittsbesuch nach paris auf es
gibt einige vorgänger heute die ein
tränchen verdrücken beim gedanken an
ihre familie eben hallen ich
wahrscheinlich den größten klang
schuldig dafür dass sie diesen weg der
für sie auch nicht immer einfach gewesen
es mitnehmen und beim gedanken dann ihre
fehler es war die bisher größte aufgabe
meines lebens mit allen höhen mit allen
tiefen
gesundheitsminister sparen übergibt
demütig an gesundheitsminister
lauterbach es gibt viele reden mit
selbstkritik heute und einer ohne der
stil den ich erlebt habe auch im
untersuchungsausschuss auch gegenüber
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter dieses
hauses die zu krankheitsfällen geführt
haben den stil den wünsche ich ihnen
nicht herr kollege wissen für
verkehrsminister wissing für sein ganzes
kabinett verspricht olaf scholz am abend
im zdf einen neuen stil keinen minister
schwach machen sondern alle stark ich
glaube einen solchen stil der durchaus
was neues in deutschland wäre den können
wir gemeinsam prägen dann können wir
auch gemeinsam zur nächsten wahl
antreten
jetzt geht es an die arbeit sagt angela
merkel und jetzt meint sie die arbeit
der anderen dann nimmt sie die blumen
und dann nimmt sie feierabend
bevor wir uns gleich dem neuen
gesundheitsminister und seinen
herausforderungen zuwenden zunächst mit
blick auf diesen tag des
regierungswechsels 1 kommentar vom
leiter der heute journal redaktion wolf
schließe
rundum gelungen ist dieser machtwechsel
und was für ein unterschied wir haben
doch alle noch die verstörenden bilder
aus washington vor augen wie ein mob das
capitol stürmte aufgehetzt von trump der
sein präsidentenamt nicht räumen wollte
wie wohltuend da der heutige tag eine so
reibungslose fast freundschaftliche
übergabe schafft vertrauen und gibt
sicherheit beides brauchen wir dringend
denn selten zuvor stand die
bundesrepublik auf so wackeligen beinen
das land ist erschöpft von fast zwei
jahren pandemie und in teilen tief
zerstritten so tief dass
gesundheitspolitiker polizeischutz
brauchen so tief dass sich impfgegner
als sündenböcke fühlen und sich familien
und freunde voneinander abwenden auf
olaf scholz und seine regierung waren
absurd große aufgaben den klimawandel
bremsen millionen neue wohnungen bauen
und putin wie peking respekt lehrern
respekt vor unserer gesellschaft die mit
sich kämpft und hart die fehler macht
und in manchem scheitert weil eine
demokratie eben nie nur ums nackte
überleben kämpft sondern immer auch um
die freiheit
durchgreifen sollte die neue
bundesregierung das zaudern muss enden
angesichts der pandemie mit ihren immer
neuen varianten scholz muss mutig
vorangehen aber auch jenen die hände
reichen die sich in die ecke gedrängt
fühlen er muss versuchen alle
mitzuziehen sonst droht auch unserer
demokratie longo wird
diese kommentiert auf dem neuen
gesundheitsminister wird jedenfalls ein
besonderes augenmerk legen als sein
vorgänger jens spahn seinerzeit das amt
übernahm hatte er nicht was auf ihn
zukommen sollte karl lauterbach immerhin
geht sehenden auges in den sturm dazu
gleich noch ein interview mit ihm noch
bevor er im bundestag vereidigt wurde
kamen schon neue nachrichten von der
virus von das gibt erste
studienergebnisse zu omikron und diese
nicht schön um es gleich vorweg zu sagen
bitte auch die korona zahlen die diesen
politischen tag heute überschatten mehr
als
69.000 gemeldeten neuinfektionen
und 527 neue todesfälle an einem tag und
was kommt damit dem mikro auf uns zu da
ist noch einiges unklar welche neuen
informationen es heute gab fast benjamin
sie allofs zusammen
bei der mainzer akademie wollten sie
heute unbeschwert die beiden gründer
feiern mit dem preis für
zukunftsweisende forschung doch omikron
die neue variante überlagert die
preisverleihung igor levit spielt doch
die probleme bleiben
nach neuesten studien ist nämlich eine
zweifache impfung gegen omikron auch mit
dem bajonett impfstoff nicht ausreichend
sie bietet zwar schutz gegen schwere
erkrankungen richtig sicher sei aber
wohl nur eine dritte impfung gegen die
krone variante
wie sie es so wir sehen auch eine
dramatische reduktion des schutzes gegen
omikron sie ist 25 mal geringer als
gegen die anderen ursprungs varianten
die wirkung des impfstoffs lässt also
nach trotzdem gibt es hoffnung was aber
auch in diesen daten drinsteckt und das
ist die positive nachricht ist dass eine
dritte impfung der booster impfung der
wissen wer das hebt den antikörper
spiegel noch mal an und dann verbessert
sich auch die nord relations' kraft
gegen die omikron variante und das gibt
hoffnung dass wir mit den mustern die
auf dem richtigen weg sind noch
deutlicher aber die ergebnisse einer
studie der uniklinik frankfurt main von
heute danach hatten zweifach geimpfte
mit verschiedenen stoffen nach sechs
monaten 0% neutralisation also schutz
vor mikron und sogar dreifach geimpfte
mit biontech hatten nach drei monaten
nur 25 prozent schutz gegen die variante
im vergleich gegen delta sind das thema
und 90 prozent die variante die bisher
dem immunschutz am meisten entgangen ist
war bitter und da hat man ein abfall von
vierfach oder 6 fach und jetzt reden wir
von einem abfall von 40 fach das heißt
da sieht man schon dass viele antikörper
jetzt nicht mehr gegen omikron wirken
und deshalb ist es meiner meinung nach
notwendig dass wir auch einen impfstoff
dann anpassen anpassen bei paion tag
arbeitet man daran es dauert aber
die ersten chargen eines an omikron
angepassten impfstoffes planen wir im
märz nächsten jahres liefert fertig zu
haben vorbehaltlich der behördlichen
zulassung
drei monate also warten mit einer sich
stark ausbreitenden corona variante und
einer neuen bundesregierung die schon
ein tag eins von omikron eingeholt wird
reichen die maßnahmen der politik die
maßnahmen müssen jetzt eben auch an die
neue realität einer neuen variante die
den impfschutz unterwandert unterwandern
kann angepasst werden das heißt
maßnahmen für die eindämmung eines
solchen ausbruchs müssen getroffen
werden auf keinen fall können wir
riskieren dass die omikron welle jetzt
zusätzlich zu der immer noch hohen del
tabelle kommt omikron ein neuer
herausfordernde akteur ist da für
gesellschaft und neue regierung
speziell für den neuen
gesundheitsminister guten abend herr
lauterbach guten armstrong kann ja kaum
im amt schon geht es direkt in die
vollen aber sie sind ja nun wahrlich im
stoff mikron wir haben es eben gehört
professor sander sagt da muss sich die
gesellschaft darauf vorbereiten wie
bereiten sie sich und uns auf diese neue
variante vor die ergebnisse die wir
heute gesehen haben sind nicht ganz
überraschend zu bestätigen leider
negative ergebnisse die wir schon
kannten somit ist die neue realität die
die impfung ist nur abgeschlossen wenn
man drei mal geimpft wurde also der
bürger muss quasi verstehen haben wir
früher immer gesagt zwei impfungen erste
und zweite impfung das ist ein
kompletter impfschutz und dann kommt
später eine musterung um den impfstoff
zum schutz zu verlängern wir müssen das
jetzt so sehen man braucht drei
impfungen überhaupt vor oregon
einigermaßen geschützt zu sein sonst
kommen wir hier nicht klar und wir
müssen natürlich dafür sorgen dass
omikron so spät kommt wie möglich aber
auch selbst bei drei impfungen jetzt der
studie von von von professor sieg aus
frankfurt war die immunität antwort
deutlich gesenkt also auch da ist man
offenbar nicht mehr so geschützt oder
bezieht sich das nur auf das auf die
infektiosität
das bezieht sich zunächst einmal auf die
ansteckung also wie schwer die
erkrankung verläuft das kann ja in
diesen also experimenten nicht gemessen
werden und es gibt auch studien die
etwas optimistischer zum glück sind das
die studie von vc sekte nicht desto
trotz eine sehr wichtige studie ist was
wir klar sagen können ist dass folgende
also dass wir werden wir hier vor
ansteckung geschützt sein wollen auch
eingeschränkt dann brauchen wir drei
impfungen mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit
wird es aber so sein dass also sogar nur
die zwei impfungen die krankheit
abmildern und drei impfungen
wahrscheinlich sehr gut gegen schwere
krankheit schützen kann man denn dann
überhaupt noch bei 2g zb von 25 und
sprechen oder müsste man sagen leute tut
uns furchtbar leid vollständig geimpft
seither ab sofort erst ab der dritten
wenn wir tatsächlich die omikron welle
hier in deutschland hätten dann wäre
tatsächlich zweig dann erreicht wenn man
quasi die dritte impfung hat dann werden
kann mit zwei impfungen
wahrscheinlich dann nicht davon ausgehen
dass man geschützt ist vor der infektion
was hat ja eine gewisse bedeutung weil
wir wollen ja durch die zweijährigen
auch die
infektionsketten unterbrechen aber wir
werden diese brücke überqueren wenn wir
sie erreicht haben noch geht es ja darum
die infektion mit omikron in deutschland
die schnelle ausbreitung zu verhindern
jetzt sagen sie große bridge von ihr
kann tritt also wir schauen mal das ist
so ein bisschen auf sicht fahren aber
eigentlich jetzt epidemiologe müssten
sie doch sagen wir sind vor die lage
kommen also die mischung ist vorbereiten
auf omikron und nicht erst wenn es voll
da ist sagen
dass du ja das tun wir ja die wichtigste
maßnahme die wir überhaupt jetzt also
wir haben zwei säulen auf die wir
aufbauen können eine ist bereits quasi
in unserer hand für eine zweite kämpfen
wir die säule die wir in der hand haben
ist die folgende wir müssen so viele
poster impfungen platzieren wie möglich
wir müssen wirklich diese nachricht
überbringen jemand ist nur vollständig
geimpft wenn der drei impfungen nannte
das ist wenn man so will eine optimale
vorbereitung auf einer mikrowelle wenn
sie denn käme die zweite säule die haben
wir noch nicht das ist eine solle jetzt
spreche ich nicht als
bundesgesundheitsminister sondern
einfach als abgeordneter karl lauterbach
wir brauchen eine allgemeine impfpflicht
denn wir werden es nicht schaffen mit
einer variante wie omikron klar zu
kommen wenn wir so große impflücken
haben wie wir befürchten müssen wenn wir
ohne impfpflicht in einer solchen lage
hinein gehen aber selbst wenn eine
solche impfpflicht käme und da gibt es
ja noch viele bands also auch
verfassungsrechtliche wenn es dann wird
das erst in wochen geschehen also
vielleicht im märz vielleicht im april
das nutzt uns da jetzt in den nächsten
wochen nichts und die krankenhäuser sind
schon voll also wir hören ja auch
virologen fordern mehr ein
dämmungsmaßnahmen ist haben sie bisher
auch getan jetzt 70 gesundheitsminister
jetzt müssen sie gucken dass sie die
auch mehrheitsfähig machen oder das tue
ich auch und daran arbeite ich ja ich
hab doch schon beispiele vorzuzeigen ich
habe mich ja zum beispiel sehr stark
auch also in den medien dafür eingesetzt
dass in den schulen wieder die masken
pflicht eingeführt wird ich habe für 2g
zweig plus immer geworben also für die
schließung von diskotheken bars und
clubs das ist jetzt auch im
infektionsschutzgesetz also was wir am
freitag beschließen das heißt die
vorsichtige position für die ich als
wissenschaftler immer stand die werde
ich nicht aufgeben nur weil ich es das
amt des gesundheitsministers begleitet
sie waren vor allem auch immer sehr
vorsichtig was kinder angeben haben
gesagt wir dürfen der korona bei kindern
nicht verharmlosen sie haben aber jetzt
ein stiko chef der sagt ich würde meine
kinder er nicht impfen für kinder ist
das harmlos was sagen sie als
gesundheitsminister dazu jetzt an dieser
neuen position also das ist eine
unglückliche positionierung gewesen von
deren herzen sich glaube es auch aus dem
zusammenhang daher aus also zitiert
worden
ganz klar ist folgendes zu sagen wir
müssen davon ausgehen dass also gerade
die omikron variante für kinder
besonders bedrohlich ist dass das ist
leider so dass die omikron variante sich
nicht nur schneller verbreitet sondern
leider auch kinder stärker befällt und
somit auch zu mir
krankenhauseinweisungen führen wird das
heißt wir müssen hier vor bauen ich
hoffe dass wir sehr bald zu einer stiko
bewertung der impfstoffe auch kommenden
da das gruppe der fünf bis zwölfjährigen
und bei den älteren ist es so also ich
persönlich
also jetzt als wissenschaftler
gesprochen glaube dass die impfung die
bessere wahl ist im vergleich zur
erkrankung herr lauterbach noch noch
kurz am schluss sie hatten heute die
übergabe mit jens spahn und da merkte
man ihrem vorgänger an an einer stelle
mindestens war der wirklich sehr bewegt
unter stockte dem auch so etwas die
stimme als er sagt das war die schwerste
aufgabe meines lebens sie hat das auf
sie gewirkt ist ihnen auch etwas mulmig
war dieser aufgabe die sie jetzt
übernehmen also mir ist ganz klar dass
das die schwerste aufgabe auf meines
lebens sein wird denn also wir sind in
einer krise das ist die größte
gesundheitskrise deutschlands nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg ich werde versuchen
das ist das ziel meiner arbeit alles
andere kommt danach aber auch wichtig
aber ich werde versuchen uns gut durch
die jetzt noch kommenden wellen der
pandemie zu bringen und ich hoffe diese
pandemie mit den kräften des hauses und
den wissenschaftlern mit denen ich sehr
eng zusammenarbeite beenden zu können
das ist meine das ist die aufgabe der
ich mich auch messen lassen muss
lauterbach wir werden uns dazu
sicherlich noch einige male sprechen und
den laufenden nächsten monaten ich danke
erst mal für heute für das internet ich
danke ihnen und nachher im heute-journal
update gibt es vor allem auch zum thema
omikron noch ein wissenschaftliches
gespräch mit dem virologen jörg timm mit
corona geht es jetzt auch eine
nachrichten erst noch immer weiter heinz
der britische premierminister johnson
hat eine verschärfung der korona maßen
haben in england angekündigt unter
anderem werde ab freitag die masken
pflicht ausgeweitet erklärte johnson am
abend ab montag sollten arbeitnehmer
dann möglichst von zu hause aus arbeiten
johnson sagte es sei zunehmend klar
geworden dass romy con sich sehr viel
schneller ausbreite als die delta
variante
die neue österreichische regierung hält
an den plänen für ein auslaufen des
corona lockdown zh fest die
beschränkungen endeten am sonntag sagt
der bundeskanzler hammer für ungeimpfte
sollten sie jedoch bestehen bleiben und
einzelne regionen könnten auch strengere
massnahmen anordnen
nach den usa haben auch kanada
australien und großbritannien einen
diplomatischen boykott der olympischen
winterspiele 2022 in china angekündigt
premierminister johnson sagte im
parlament in london kein minister seiner
regierung oder funktionäre zu den
spielen nach peking reisen die usa
hatten diesen schritt am montag
verkündet und mit
menschenrechtsverletzungen in china
begründet die regierung in peking
reagierte mit scharfer kritik
in gleich zwölf bundesländern sind zoll
und bundespolizei gegen mutmaßliche
menschen schleuser vorgegangen bei den
razzien wie hier in berlin wurden zehn
verdächtige festgenommen
sie sollen illegale arbeitskräfte vor
allem aus der ukraine und moldawien mit
gefälschten papieren ausgestattet und an
große deutsche logistikunternehmen
vermittelt haben bis zu 1000 menschen
sollen auf diese weise hierzulande in
den arbeitsmarkt gelangt sein
nach dem vulkanausbruch auf der
indonesischen insel java ist die zahl
der toten auf mindestens 39 gestiegen
mehr als zwölf menschen werden noch
vermisst
schwere regenfälle und neue lavaströme
haben die suche nach vermissten
erschwert zahlreiche dörfer wurden mit
vulkanischem schlamm überschwemmt der
einsatz von schwerem gerät sei laut
behörden unter diesen bedingungen im
katastrophengebiet um den vulkan nicht
möglich
und jetzt zur wirtschaft und damit noch
mal zurück zum wechsel der
bundesregierung frank bethmann welche
forderungen kommen aus der wirtschaft an
die neue regierung daher zunächst mal
auffällig dass aus sicht der unternehmen
und der interessenvertreter der
grundsätzliche kurs der ampel stimme
vielfach war der wunsch zu hören bessere
planungssicherheit in der partie vor
allem aber merkte man den äußerungen an
eine schonfrist wird es nicht geben die
neue bundesregierung muss jetzt beweisen
dass sie ihre vielen vorhaben wirklich
umsetzen kann sagt zum beispiel der
präsident des groß handelsverbandes bga
auch der industrieverband bdi macht
druck das angekündigte jahrzehnte der
zukunftsinvestition muss realität werden
die vorsitzende der jungen unternehmer
hingegen beklagt es weiter so in der
rentenpolitik notwendig werden jetzt
grundlegende reformen um die rente
zukunftsfest zu machen dafür reiche die
angedachte aktien rente offenbar nicht
aus hoffnungen und enttäuschungen also
den ersten stellungnahmen an diesem
mittwoch an dem der dax heute nach gibt
127 punkte verliert frank bethmann
vielen dank
und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
15 16 18
26 39 44 superzahl 5 und weitere
gewinnzahlen könnten sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
im vergleich der ausführliche
wetterbericht kommt hier schon der
hinweis auf unwetterwarnungen des
deutschen wetterdienstes vor starkem
schneefall für teile von
baden-württemberg und bayern
zum ersten mal seit zwölf jahren hat
russland wieder weltraumtouristen zur
iss geflogen ein japanischer milliardär
und sein assistent starteten um 8 38
mitteleuropäischer zeit vom weltraum
startplatz baikonur in kasachstan
mit an bord der rakete vom typ sojus war
auch ein russischer kosmonaut
sechs stunden dauerte der flug zur
raumstation
zwölf tage werden sie nun in rund 400
kilometern über der erde verbindet
das war es von uns gleich nach dem
wetter geht es mit dem auslandsjournal
weiter unter anderem mit einem bericht
aus portugal das ja eine besonders hohe
impfquoten hat und um 00 50 gibt es dann
unser heute schon ein update mit
christina von sternberg bis morgen auf
wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend der deutsche wetterdienst
hat heute eine statistik zu weißen
weihnachten vorgelegt er hat zwei klima
referenzperiode miteinander verglichen
in den 1970 er jahren gab es in münchen
etwa alle drei jahre weiße weihnachten
in den 2000er jahren etwa nur noch alle
sieben jahre in frankfurt am main ist
der unterschied noch krasser gab es in
den 1970 er jahren etwa alle sechs jahre
weiße weihnachten gab es in den 2000er
jahren nur noch etwa alle 18 jahre weiße
weihnachten im zuge des klimawandels
liegt eben viel seltener an heiligabend
am ersten und am zweiten weihnachtstag
schnee wie das in diesem jahr sein wird
wissen wir nicht aber wir wissen dass
bis morgen früh am albrand innerhalb von
24 stunden durchaus 20 bis 40 zentimeter
neuschnee gefallen sein werden und dann
lässt der schneefall aber erstmal nach
heute nacht kann es aber eigentlich
überall wieder glatt sein nicht nur dort
wo es noch länger schneit oder noch
länger schnee regen fällt denn die
temperaturen sinken auf plus 2 bis minus
4 grad und morgen bleibt es beim
leichten dauerfrost im nordosten mit
minus 1 oder -2 grad im westen wird es
milder am rhein geht's auf fünf oder
sechs grad rauf und doch morgen flog das
noch leicht in der osthälfte hier
zwischen der nordseeküste und dem
sauerland kommt auch mal die sonne zum
vorschein und von westen ziehen neue
schnee regen wolken auf die breiten sich
dann am freitag etwas weiter richtung
südwesten aus am samstag schneit es noch
im süden und der dritte advent wird von
nordwesten deutlich milder guten abend